texas on saturday at allegiant stadium
they are one-on-one after saturday's
tough loss at cal sophomore quarterback
doug brumfield has looked pretty good in
those first two games and transfer
running back aidan robbins has been
putting on a show with four touchdowns
in the first two games robbins 6-3 230
is a huge addition for the rebels he has
already graduated from louisville but
now has two years eligibility left the
big number nine is loving his new home
here in las vegas
yes it's a huge difference it's like
night and day almost i mean you know you
got dry heat here you got humidity back
at home um you know we got a lot of
trees back at home here not so much you
know so got palm trees here but you know
it's still football though you still got
to put the ball down and play we got a
good group of guys you know they work
hard and you know we're definitely
creating a nice culture here
all right kick off with the rebels in
north texas
that's at noon over to legion stadium
we'll be right back